[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everybody good morning
it's Tuesday and you know we're here at
GameSpot live Persia David and we're
playing some remnant from the ashes
reminisce from the ashes man hot off the
presses hype game dude hide game we got
a character right here yeah I mean we're
just jumping right into it obviously
this game has been super hype everyone's
been looking forward to it and yeah so
this is you know we just started it
takes you to character customization
screen obviously you get all the goods
you know choose male/female pick your
hair pick your skin tone pick the eye
color although I think green is the only
proper choice here because look how
beautiful yeah we got it we got a very
soulful looking fella here and we try to
make him look a little like old and why
like he's been around the bush he knows
what's up you seen some some demons who
slayed a couple of them so yeah we'll
just dive right in I was just yeah with
the hair I want to I'll go with this guy
looks like looks like it you did
yourself I thank like a lighter alright
yes so we're just jumping right now and
we already looked through the
customization options but we want to see
the gameplay you know so that's what we
aren't doing thank you all for tuning in
and welcome to GameSpot live David's
gonna be handling the gameplay here so
if you want to hate on the gameplay you
direct all that towards I'll take it
I'll take you but yeah
you must discover intro scene to our
last hope
save this scene before what's up crime
everybody in the chat I'll be familiar
feet dry my boys mr. price is not
excited over the exact reason use oh I'm
sure you I'm sure everybody in the
office it's pretty exciting a Phoenix
I've always enjoyed games that let you
customize a character and then puts your
character in the cutscenes oh snap
[Music]
I am doing good max town thank you her
at the end she could bleed the red
that's something that twisted and turned
look at him on an adventure
braving the storms the Dragons talent I
love
with their stupid it's like he meets out
I played a lot of Dragon Age
no moderators house I'm trying to get
rid of the other method oh it's moving
when I last they got there we go another
place a lot of people have compared the
narrator for most games is the Dark
Souls II hmm and like the trailers and
stuff and yeah Alucard actually just
said a pretty well RPG Souls ish we had
a couple of videos myself and another
senior producer here Aaron we did some
breakdowns and how feminine is very
similar to Dark Souls but it's a little
easier I'm still gonna die well I
believe in you we are actually playing
on PC today I know we play a lot of
games on ps4 but this is on PC but we
are using an Xbox one controller so say
I press B to crouch is this multiplayer
says well if I lose so yeah you can play
with how many like four or three I think
I think it's like three people three
yeah you and two other people and the
devs when I met with them they actually
strongly encourage you to play with
other people hmm um I think it's more oh
I bet
[Applause]
love I like how they just started you
damaged oh oh okay we're just so bored
really jumping right in creepy looking
oh he's throwing bang love your own okay
slice and dice surrogate
dodging and sprinting depletes your
stamina got it
oh wow the range the range yes you got
like the health bar on the bottom right
Sam in a bar
both staples of a lot of like Oh ding
yeah I agree with that yes this game did
come out today you guys good want to
check it out yourself so just just as a
full disclosure I think you're actually
supposed to die
but one of those they make it extra
tough to progress the story line it's a
little loud and turned down slightly
sure but you're skillful we're gonna
survive anyways forget that cutscene we
don't need it this guy yeah they like
specifically don't have any any like
health right now like they're not giving
you any consumables now you get good
David get good dodge and weave you can
dodge a wrench you can dodge a
crazy-looking
I don't even know what these things are
called human boys demon boys wait this
sounds too hype they're evil I like the
sound
some ominous that is true mecca's pig
you can also play as a female character
yes thank you male or female customize
them they can look funky make me look
cool they can look like clowns it's all
up to you so remnant is a third-person
survival action shooter even though we
don't have a gun yet but I'm hearing
some someone busted some shots over
there so yeah oh oh ding oh he's out oh
he like blinks and all of a sudden stabs
oh what a boss no pain no gain
wait they're like trees yeah he needs
help
crime said I should play and stream
Blair Witch and turn off the lights in
the room when it comes out I'm playing I
am planning I'm putting it on the stream
although I apologize in advance for all
the times I streak into the mic because
jump scares are just too free for me and
like you weren't in the five nights
oh my what are you worried I actually
did pretty well though I didn't get
better than me I got bodied a couple
times by the body the competitive side
of me really wanted me to finish a level
I got to like v 900 ding ohh
it's michaelski do they have spines I
don't know I think they're just like one
being or something I don't know one
China is this free to play no it isn't a
lot I do not believe so but it's
available on PC Xbox and Playstation 4
yeah yeah yeah yeah just trying to make
sure I have all my details correct here
[Music]
accra said this seems like a game I'd
rather just watch and not purchase
honestly I kind of like that about how
streaming has become because sometimes I
want to like at least see a bunch of
games or I might not be able to buy it
or I can't afford it or I don't have
like a PC to play on or something like
that so I just hop on Twitch and watch
and you know there you still get that
enjoyment of checking out the game even
though you don't get to play for me Oh
Dave who are you or where am I hmm wait
are we we're talking as us right
we're yeah I wouldn't know where I am
I'm trying to think if I was there I'd
be like where am I thirteen who's the
commander we were on a boat we already
know it brought you here they said they
said mark was it coming back was that
mark who got rekt oh yeah it had to have
been a mess of wine never mind
the commander said you should come see
her when you woke up she's down in the
room
goddess all right later bring down the
hall smell you later kid
can you play split screen as far as I
didn't know you cannot but you can play
multiplayer with other people right
who are also online right right and we
are playing some remnant from the ashes
Nathan just came out today hot off the
presses you play game designers need to
up their hair game I don't know man like
I kind of fresh it's with rigs
downstairs worried where's my weapon
I'm commander Ford it's my job to know
the kind of people we haven't seen you
will tell me eventually it's like I
can't take any more tags I just give the
people what they want
oh alright are we gonna be forceful our
needs are you in I don't need to tell
you anything
are we gonna be like you know tactical
do you think oh no these they're
strangers right we don't know how Bucky
they are
let's just be tactful at first no no no
that's our in a very long time
disrespecting you this is word has been
cut off got a block of gays after the
routes definitely cousins definitely
what's your idea commander for tell you
what you want to leave all right excuse
me we survived that opening missiles
level thank you very much reactor the
reactor is on the lower basement get it
running then come back here nothing
around here is easy alright so a
question for the chat I don't know if
you guys are aware but there is I know
there's two secrets there might be three
before you start your first mission and
if you guys know now would be a good
time to let me know we're basically
looking for a SMG
a armor piece that you can get before
you start I see so we can scavenge
around woo the secret tips and tricks
here on gamespot live ladies and
gentlemen from the one and only gameplay
master David himself because I actually
I had the footage showing that the the
secret guide and stuff but I totally
forgot what I did nice separates well
your sword
okay we got to look for ace good luck
down and go down the reactor get some
new weapons oh snap
you lost cool oh dang what you looking
at she like she's like I'm just working
on my on my machine you go on get
because here's a director we want to get
to the ward 13 yeah happy to be on l1
but we need this SMG though yeah well
that's um she's gonna happen after okay
I thought them we were going to the
mission see this is why wait one more
yeah oh this is why I can't like when I
play games like this it takes me
probably three times as long to finish
as anything else cuz I'm like I would
look everywhere that's shot oh that
looks like loot moves like you need a
key card to get in
hey what's up the hair conjure a meme or
something yeah alright see the people in
the chat talking about the hair in the
game honestly we can be super real there
are very very few games if any of that I
think ever really nail hair in a game
yeah that's somehow one of the most
difficult things in in just game history
how do we make this hair look realistic
I've seen some games do a really good
job as of late for sure
I mean Heron water seem to be - like
really difficult things for people who
work on graphics to kind of like try and
figure out you know yeah Ritchie in the
chat ganking Ritchie you assembly the
gameplay gang's all here
okay so beats use a no-go at the moment
so it seems like maybe it was just a
reactor level anyway okay so b1 this is
where we want to be this must be ace
oh snap you were like super close for
freshness
[Laughter]
there's no peripheral vision yeah I
winged it literally every day my motto
okay
you go upstairs and start the reactor
I'll help you kill whatever comes our
way ideal you probably need a weapon huh
all right we pick someone earlier and
Chad asked if there were archetypes so
here we are now got three definitely
archetypes hunter right X occultist X
cultist
and this rapper okay so scrapper oh nice
specializes close range combat melee
makes sense he's scrapping so aside from
these hands he's got a shout out tells
you about their weaponry as well X
cultists special specializes in mid
range combat and support okay nice and
then the long range the hunter armed
with an ultra precise hunting rifle
noise oh yeah yeah what are we feeling
I've seen I've seen everyone do the X
cultist for like the longest time so I'm
because he I was like a heel and he
doesn't answer he's kind of like you
know all around I think on my account at
home I'm gonna do hunter except to
capture gameplay for that but if you all
want to see some action we could
probably go scrapper just get right yeah
the scrapper looks cool I don't want to
throw some hands hey well Ritchie says
shoddy yeah I'm saying yeah show us a
scrapper and Mario madness is it gives
you really good armor and the Hot Shot
is super deadly noise so let's yeah that
sounds like a winner winner
okay so we got a treatment YouTube so
this is what we got here
dang you took marks pistol
got the shotgun the scrap hammer Oh got
inventory stuff no consumables traits
here we go vigor endurance and warrior
and I've got zero trade points at the
moment we got that we got a we're gonna
up that stuff all right so toggle
weapons this is a shotgun
it's the pistol okay so no swords
anymore unfortunately and that's right
yeah I'm more of a shooter anyway
exactly can't bring a sword to a
gunfight yeah yeah alright let's
activate this stuff
oh there's terminals - we're not gonna
linger over these for too long but
basically there's a lot of good Lord
here a lot of things in the world that
kind of are set a certain way you know
there might be like you might stumble on
an asylum or like a research facility
that's like completely nuked and it's
all like desolate and you're trying to
figure out you know what happened here
there's these terminals you can log in
and kind of you know check them out see
what's going on yeah honestly stuff like
this I feel like are in the game because
maybe later on down the road there might
be something that'll like be tied into
that totally alright and there are there
are a lot of people who just enjoyed
lore in general you know totally totally
good
Andy Pandy yes at the beginning when
you're creating your character you can
choose between a man or a woman
so definitely can play is be more
familiar
o'night is a mallet come on let's
tenderize these trees ooh oh dang oh
dang they're hitting me with the combos
now come save you oh no no I'm saving
hurry dude the teamwork
Katsuji played how new treats are
commands I don't know we might we might
stumble on one actually man that's
convenient they just disintegrate no
cleaning no nothing sick dodge rolls I
told you guys this is gameplay we signed
up for this is why you're here
alright let's return to commander Ford
so something else really cool about this
game is that you can explore like each
of these worlds in here like if you on
the left so you can see them all but
they change every time you go through
them all right so you know replay value
right because you're likely gonna play
this over again if you want to check out
how the other classes work or if you
want to get like a character in each
class buff yeah you're always gonna be
playing through it multiple times but
the fact that even the world itself
changes through it's pretty cool
there yeah that's it's randomly
generated for a lot of these things so
it's like it's kind of like dungeons
that folks you don't know stranger
currently playing on PC but it's also
available for Xbox and Playstation this
is my dad like your brother yeah
Oh actually yeah I look older than in
destiny about destiny you're gonna see
the world ain't ya a dragon all right
now we know there's dragons that's
that's a real important right there
dragon heart can we use replenish lost
health there are a limited number of
uses before its power is depleted
charges are planning alright so for
those of you who played Dark Souls you
might know this as a Estus flask right
or a blood vial for you blood-borne
folks out there so it seems like we've
got that there although I don't know
where it said I had it olv okay I
thought it was gonna go over ends here
yeah yeah controls but I thought too
okay let's check out the map let's get
to commander Ford so we can go out into
the world I think I'm gonna move our
camera here because it's covering our
objectives hold how do you know
glad to see you got the react and I very
well you've proven yourself stranger but
I doubt you'll last longer
go see rigs and McCabe downs come see me
afterwards
alright we're gonna get better gear down
tunic yeah pretty much just going on a
couple of fetch quests get her CIL's
kitted out exactly it's warming you up
for the real stuff yeah you guys for
those of you in chat is there anything
specific about this game you guys are
looking forward to maybe we can try to
keep an eye out for it or try to help
show it off yeah sally-ann says you
should do reviews and stuff whoa
GameSpot definitely does tons of reviews
you guys should check them out we've got
a a squad team yeah our review team is
stellar
they're great yeah they're the best so
yeah definitely check those out no less
may turn up it's a hell of a time to
visit the ward friend friend it's not
Riggs is it I was right no actually you
know who Riggs was I think Riggs is that
person who told us to keep walking oh
yeah doing super rude mm-hmm so I gotta
see and I don't even remember which
direction we came No well this is a
reactor that we triggered everything
right but then we come in
the other side you know let's go back to
that main floor and then yeah where is
the map I mean the directory or whatever
how good is aiming in this game and is
it hard it feels pretty good actually a
little bit of a little bit of shooting
that I did it felt it felt fine Moscow
it's not gonna let me see who's who is
just gonna have sick nope yeah I learn
on your own and you better remember
these names that's actually really good
training cuz I'm horrible or remembering
people's names so I like Mario madness
says you already passed the room and now
you're just going backward we pass it
the stream chat is also delayed by like
30 seconds or something I think oh I
think if this might be here no that's a
kid no definitely the one in charge of
the armoury tell us what floor it's on
it's on l1 or the basement or b1 didn't
the map I mean the directory on the wall
say what floor mmm where's the director
he was near the door right ye it's
usually before the stairs is this
cross-play hmm
although cross-play is starting to it's
starting to happen you guys slowly but
surely
there we go what you know what we spent
she's over it like five minutes looking
for you you yeah hello to you too wow
we're having words she's a scrapper to
know is this dropping thanks I can be as
grumpy as I damn well please yes you lay
down sir serious hurt that's all you get
get me more component now get out of
here
I'm tired of you yeah yeah weapon mods
so we can augment kind of what we have I
think someone mentioned the chat earlier
that hotshot dreamer scrapper was kind
of the ish she put on the shotgun and
we'll try that out oh yeah I know it's
like let's get to the action now we've
run around 400 cutscene this is good
news man they're so friendly to someone
they just met up in and guns and armor
okay so he's just the guy that we go to
you to upgrade this stuff whenever we
can take this it's nice that's yes
scrapper iron man armor that we were
looking at bloodhound armor yeah I look
ready to rumble oh yeah Yousef I that
happens to me all the time like you meet
somebody and then the second time you
meet them you're trying to remember
their name and you can't you're like oh
hey man yeah what's up what's up dude
like oh it's you and I'm hoping like
someone walks by and like you know says
their name or something near these I'm
like I can remember again bomb like man
I know I knew your name at one point
yeah what's the photo
mark Etsy so we're ready to rock
let's do this we have our armor good to
see you more quick I hope this will be
in we can't leave oh yeah we're in there
now
he said we should only use well
considering you there's determined with
any luck I got a key all right so we got
armor we got a key we got some weapons
you see at the command room terminal key
box I think we're ready
command room terminal pro game Reyes
says reminds me of gears and doom mixed
together fair what's a good comparison
fair oh dang I think I know access here
oneida I've got the key have you ever
seen the show the 100
I've been catching up on them finally
and like on the last season last few
episodes but you know it's along the
lines of apocalyptic world stuff so it's
like every time they meet other human
beings just hostility on site so I'm
like man they're so nice to like a
stranger they just interesting amongst
these mystical crystals yeah so this is
kind of like the blood borne lanterns or
like the bonfire pits and like Dark
Souls and sizes basically where you can
go to to regen there's an old dragon
hearts and also fast travel once you
unlock more and like those other worlds
they are you talking about well
thankfully you don't need someone in
chat mention earlier that they're
getting like Carol from The Walking Dead
vibes from this character I definitely
agree yeah yeah yeah you guys want to
see all the cutscenes yeah cuz I'm
already ready to like oh the sessions
now join okay yeah all right let me see
here this lets you do interesting
that's troubling other destinations the
world settings the campaign is now
active okay you can reroll the campaign
I'm not going to do that now cuz it's
gonna bring him back to the beginning
but essentially you can replay bits of
the campaign with like different random
more random settings and that's pretty
fun but so we only have this one here
the founders hideout and let's go to oh
so it's like the first real mission
mm-hmm I want to show ya but I'm also
kind of thinking that we're in the
founders hideout right now like this is
just that checkpoint for that location
there actually no double-o to says he's
downloading this game right now ready to
die yeah I mean you kind of just have to
expect it a little bit sometimes with
these games alright so I wanna check out
Ward 13 again real quick mecha robot
says how do you rate the game I've been
interested in it from what I've seen but
does it play as good as it looked in
trailers hey please alright we're very
early in so far but if it feels pretty
good but you can you can definitely
check out some of our impressions from
preview vents that we've had that Aaron
Sampson has done and he he's big on the
game he enjoys it a lot so that's that's
you know something to kind of consider
all right I'm gonna find this want to
look for the research facility or like
the asylum real quick and for those of
you curious about how much the game is
it's looking like it is 39.99 across the
board if you would like to buy it it's
available on PC Xbox one and PlayStation
4 mm-hmm let's go back in this reactor
and kind of walk around I'm a little
bummed out about the stamina level
because I just wanted like Springs place
is massive I'm just like out of breath
like so quick it's like me in real life
that's me running after Bart yeah don't
leave me
can you floor a crawl jump or a roll ask
Bob Jones you can roll you can like do a
little somersault it's basically um camp
floor crawl or do any any fun things
like that just yet but um but there's
some there's some definitely
maneuverability stuff all right I'm just
gonna go back to the Maronite yeah go
back to the crystal the chat agrees you
need to go back to Chris go to the
crystal crystal crystal
okay
good all right
so you're back at the crystal you'll see
where the founders hideout kind of takes
us let's just I just want to shoot
something man
Mario madness is you can slide - that's
pretty good probably yeah probably when
you sprint and then you press the thing
it'll be it'll be good today I'm gonna
have lag issues when you go to a new
location you have them but some people
have oh I mean it's a pretty new game
right so you might end up kind of
experiencing that I don't think it's
gonna be - I don't think it should be
too bad all right so we're in the
crystal we're gonna move up and we got
some she is here we got the war 13 key
card so that's what it was got some
roots got some lore I'm dying no two
ways about it always thought the route
would get me oh it's well it's the
daughter reading to your parent that's
sad moving on though
what is the labyrinth jeez good question
I miss this so just got a bunch of sort
of like sad letters and things like that
people saying goodbye to their beloved
okay so we um you get yes hello
so we uh so the first missions out there
but since we have time I just got the
war thirteen key card which means you
can go and get we're gonna snoop around
and get the secret SMG did you get it
already we got the keys for it okay so
you got a backtrack
see truth says everyone in chat this
games a mystery to me what's the closest
games you can compare it to well we said
Dark Souls earlier souls born games and
then people in chat we're also comparing
it to like a Gears doom mashup a little
bit - mm-hmm
so maybe you know medley of all those
things dark haze says his favorite
archetype is the hunter which was like
the longer and wants to know about you
guys like what's your preference even if
you haven't played it yet if you were to
pick what would be your style like
usually I would probably go with the
hunter as well I do like rains and
sniping and stuff like that but the
scrapper sounds really fun scrappers fun
I think I'll go with the X cultists and
stuff but we'll see so we got a tome of
knowledge this is basically like a
upgrade trait so if you guys get that
wart 13 key card access make sure you
double back and you can get you know a
little free upgrade this is that kind of
asylum I was talking about earlier it's
a really really creepy everything's kind
of like broken there's a lot of blood
it's like a little empty tube like no
people or hardly any people look at some
tonics a little something for the road
mm-hmm and if I recall correctly what
we're looking for is a almost like a
battery like charger mmm it's like a
long kind of like electrical batteries
gonna be in one of these rooms this is
where it gets like very like almost like
Arkham Asylum II oh man I love our
communes
so if you end up logging into any of
these computers to kind of tell you what
happened here like what went wrong
Oh creepy we are playing on PC and
someone asks is it 60 or 30fps most
likely 60 yeah on PC probably I mean I
would assume 60 is like the standard now
I could be wrong game design is
difficult I don't even know it like the
surface of anything of game design right
so I give so much props the game devs oh
that was smooth nice little roll yeah
it's pretty fun especially we do it over
like a second-story balcony and you just
like you just mob down it's it's pretty
it's pretty good it's a good time oh
yeah assassin touching on the randomly
generated worlds that we talked a little
bit about earlier but um he's mentioning
over 20 bosses and a hundred enemies as
a lot but yeah they are like randomly
generated so each time you play the
games gonna be any unique to your own
playthrough totally but as in terms of
like the multiplayer aspect I think
people can just like join your room or
join your party once you get to a point
where it's joinable like it was until
after I liked the tutorial part that it
said our party have become drainable as
awesome so yeah alright Dave you're
killing me man I need some action in my
life you don't like all this snooping
around I mean I do when it's on my own
time but right here right now we need
some action man I can only run so fast
we got all this heavy armor I ain't got
tires on your shoulders yeah heavy metal
like plates on your chest
yeah it's just that just speaks to the
the RPG person I mean I'm just like
running around trying to get all the
upgrades everything I possibly can to
get myself kitted out well that's what's
mom yeah so I picked up a fuse so if any
is a runny postman restoring the power
Jess frame deep says hi greetings from
India how's the game so far well
greetings right back at ya um we're in
pretty early parts of the game right now
haven't really jumped too far into like
combat and stuff just yet but we're
getting there yeah we're gonna get there
um he said he's heard he heard it's
filled with bugs and performance issues
on PC well we're playing on PC right now
we haven't experienced anything just yet
there were some bugs in and earlier like
preview versions and stuff but this one
I mean things have been running fine
nothing is glitch yeah that's all
something you have to kind of expect
from preview builds like they're not
finished builds either is this all
sci-fi wasteland
because enemies and the trailer looked
magical yeah I mean they were like
monster you're right so it's kind of the
dark fantasy type stuff
yeah it looks like all the separate
worlds kinda have a different style so
maybe parts of the trailer with more of
the magical looking enemies were from a
different world that we're not in yet
but I'm looking at some of them - right
like earth that's where we are right now
but I mean I'm gonna pronounce all these
rural but Yasha ROM and corss or the
other three worlds and the Asia looks
pretty magical so that might be the one
so we couldn't get the SMG I know people
in the chat we're pointing it out you
have to enable the power at the fuse box
and stuff but for the sake of time we're
just kind of moving forward yeah we're
halfway through the Schumer eighties
yeah but there's this bookshelf here
that I just destroyed and I think this
is where you get the armor at least so
that's yep so you guys got to see at
least one secret today what's right but
we have a video diary of this injury
yeah so if you guys do want to see how
to get the other awesome items the SMG
with the fuse box and stuff yeah just
check out the gameplay channel and
you'll you'll see the guide up there all
right
let's swap out oh look at that
got some someone's growling at us
Oh interesting
okay so Marlo says there is a drop-in
dropout co-op which is what we were kind
of talking about earlier when our room
became open to join but then they also
said but only the hosts campaign will
progress progress interesting so I guess
if you join someone else's game you can
help them complete it but it might not
apply towards your own personal campaign
progress trying to pull up my melee
weapon oh that's weird I think didn't
they say like right sure no that's
obviously shoot Oh
oh there it is what do you do you just
hit just the right trigger yeah yeah
yeah okay because there's no hip fires
what I was throwing me off it what it's
good yeah okay now hit fire so yeah that
makes them mm-hmm just go and scrub my
ghouls great throw these hands boy come
get me you say
boom now you thought give me all the
loose throw stuff at me rude he just
like pulls a shard out of his own body
is there is there a PvP in this game
good question I do not know yet yeah
honestly co-op right I mean I look
around will be fun if there's PvP I live
for that stuff I feel like if not now
maybe in the future mm-hmm we'll see
prepare to fight the root of all evil if
I see what you did there
yeah that is interesting crime because
we mentioned the dev said this is like a
better experience and co-op but the
progression doesn't count for you know
everyone involves so that's interesting
too if that's the case seems like you
remember had a dog right games are like
secretly a-holes about that right it's
like that's like the ongoing joke so I
always say at tournaments right like if
I just like someone losing rows oh
nothing very good now we oh gosh easy
shiny - the [ __ ] did you just spawn
another one or did that one is walk-up
for blood man yeah they live on them you
are a dinner yes that dudes like I need
this South Beach going off your blood
that's what I got you're like you a
scrapper that's a delicacy snipers too
long that I need me a scrapper
hey more meat on the bone I see a little
shiny thing up there grab it I can't
help myself
shiny new weapons degrade over a time or
was damaged good question I'm gonna
assume no
only because you know the your mallet
you know that's like a part of your kit
so you can't really unless there's other
melee weapons you can pick up and use it
might be um no I don't think it's like
that they break but I do think what is
Duff's more people with our male
anyway claim was that we just some more
people with the mallet and then let them
know it doesn't I don't see a gauge or
anything present on it so assassin says
no but you can upgrade the weapons yeah
and you can't unfreeze them we upgraded
our shotgun we added the monster them to
is that it was yeah guys come on man I'm
just getting warmed up
who Mario van is gladly you don't have
to repair his stuff one less thing to
worry about yeah sure
when he got a hundred different enemies
worried about yeah I'm listing his name
which game did they mention yesterday
that was going cross-play was I gears or
was that I remember they mentioned they
were like this is gonna be for cross
play and I was like finally
cuz I know cause it was something that I
was like I was like good stuff good
stuff
cosplay let's go started yes that little
skull on the bottom of the mat man the
thing like threw me off was kind of oh
you think it's like the objective right
spoiled spoiled by these modern games oh
yeah I need I need like checkpoints
every couple minutes please detective
mode I need I need markers let me know
where to go
yeah I started like realizing that more
and more when I tried to go back to like
older games I'm like man I'm spoiled by
his new games and these mechanics
seriously killed everyone here I know
it's too quiet
reads wait what's that orange thing in
the bottom of your screen
yeah but there's a gate maybe I smash it
oh yeah the mallet mmm see how strong is
melody yeah it has to be like a good
passive for that well maybe not but that
sounds like it would be a good passive
like break it down as you're scrap oh we
just woke up Briggs oh oh way it's still
locked okay not so bad yeah open from
the other side maybe like it's one of
those I have to walk all the way around
so like I'm lock a checkpoint or
something oh boy well let's do it seems
like that would make the most sense
interesting assassin says there's 15 to
20 hours for the story and some side
missions but obviously you could play
through it with the regenerated world so
you can get a lot more out of it but 15
to 20 hours it's not bad I think a big
thing from one of our videos when we
if this came down it was talking about
how for this might not apply to every
gamer but some of the older gamers who
might not have as much time on their
hands this kind of fits perfectly
because you can invest like 30 minutes
to an hour get through like a solid
dungeon or to have some fun and then you
know and it's like no sweat off your
back you're not left behind and a game
like love céntimos are we have to like
constantly grind yeah thanks or
something like that you know all these
on the grain absolutely
oh yeah that's dude that is bonfire AF
right there
oh god check out he says not for
everything just for like your personal
playthrough so that makes sense we're
entering junk town no shooting no
stealing no bathroom do a bathroom
that's the only reason why game yeah
that's good too pretty do these
decisions change your story at all I
don't think so or maybe oh you said the
wrong thing oh that's all we know that's
what happens when you master the story
you guys
well I got a come on baby you got this
guy's no I'm just you got that shoddy
this guy's thank you get him there we go
I was like I want your mask bro give me
that mask oh it's a week you don't like
your helmet I'm just big on on blue
hello erect him so there's that I guess
oh snap we have death stranding talk in
the chat that's stranding out some
moments yeah have you looking at
Gamescom I'm seeing a couple of hot
takes here in the chat Jess frame says
this jamming is basically a walking
piece simulator whoa hot take he says
control looks a million times better
I mean honestly like we haven't just not
seen enough of the game these are all
teasers for a reason yeah I mean those
elements are indeed in the game from
what we've seen so far but we're a
scratch on the surface here but we'll
see there's still a lot of time still
more reveals Tokyo Game Show on the
horizon I think we're gonna see a lot
more from there I just feel like I
haven't seen enough of deaths that's
trending to like figure out whether I
think it's gonna be good or not but I'm
interested in the fact that it's
something original it's obviously
something abstract and different mhm
you know Kojima obviously is gonna
influence everyone's want to play this
game or at least see what it's about but
you know with a lot of hype also comes a
lot of pressure to live up to that hype
at the same time and especially when we
live in such a cancer like culture yeah
like society right now you know they
have a lot to live up to but I don't
think that's outside of Kojima's grasp
come on have some faith it's got a good
head on his shoulders
Stasi guys hold all judgment until we
until it comes out uh-oh here we go it's
good oh wait these are like the same
guys do they respond
oh yeah probably right every time yeah
khadeem is basically a movie director
making games honestly you know with the
direction you're going with that
stranding using celebrities and actors
for you know the motion capture and all
that good stuff definitely definitely
going down that road right in the spine
but I think that definitely raises an
interesting question right originality
in story
compared to good gameplay right what
holds more weight it you know it depends
on the type of gamer you are yeah Super
Center right it's all about the style
that you play cuz I know I I enjoy good
narratives I really do I love story
games I love you know single-player
campaigns but I also love multiplayers
and PvP just like coops and stuff that I
can kind of like tune out and just you
know flex a little bit but uh frenzy
dosed about but now the point being so I
mean it gets to depends on the type of
camera you are you know my friends who
absolutely loathe campaigns like they
just don't have the patience round like
sitting through stories like they just
want players only right
and then even then they don't like multi
players like destiny where you have to
loot up and look at these perks and try
to like you know maximize your stats
like RPG games right they're not they're
not the biggest fan of that they prefer
you know overwatch where you just have
everything and what you get is what you
get right so that's kind of uh kind of
what they want but we're looking for a
subway and I can't find this far away
from me yeah where is the bargain does
this game have PvP no I mean that is our
assessment but you can play with your
friends
oh this place is now I mean if it does I
haven't seen anything about it
Oh gremlin he's just minding his own
business what what is that od you killed
the baby in our momma the root rot that
uh a boss
I don't I don't think so well because I
just see the the bottom there's like oh
you're right I'm doing another search on
PvP but no there's not okay I'm just I
needed a 100% no and now we know no pvp
but I think there's a boss in here I
definitely hear squishy movement whoa
I think it's a it's cuz I frickin malla
did it mallet did it that's right we got
our checkpoint though all right round
two let's go
Marlow called that I sense death anytime
soon
oh no I didn't we learn anything from
the front yeah it look like they'll pop
in one gunshot so I just keep trying to
hit fire Oh thing this icon makes me
want to kiss oh yeah you're right
when we switch weapons like you're using
that shotgun too much boy it's like now
you got to go back to your little pistol
ooh there's friendly fire in those games
oh this is my challenges record yeah
watch out for those of you who have a
you know happy trigger finger there yeah
okay
oh man when I used to play like hardcore
search-and-destroy all the time yeah
thanking God that would be my pet peeve
again teen killed eventually they added
ricochet or it was like you killed you
it like you hit your teammate and it
wasn't like affect you instead but then
that was even more it I mean that worse
than getting shot by your teens but if
you accidentally shot someone and killed
yourself that's fine
oh my gosh I think these little puff
balls here I need to go somewhere
whoa maybe they are all like an
accumulative part of the boss like no
once you take them all out straight
point
oh snap
was about to go my menus and I just hear
Darren's I've got portray points
available
I like our Reggie always chimes in when
you get those clutch dodges and take
that backwards dodged we're all though
it's guns too strong oh oh that's your
meter I think like every time you are
getting I'm in the the rod right gosh
Milo says once it's full you cough once
in a while making you vulnerable to
attack Oh gotcha
Thank You Marlo the chat always has yeah
got the Snapple facts Odie he knows how
to block you're gonna have to time this
he probably gets close to you and
charges up a swing or something yeah oh
[Applause]
oh oh what was that now we've really
entered the tarsals territory oh my gosh
yeah we have okay so how do you okay so
I probably have to like dodge around
maybe right yeah it was only because you
walked yourself into a tight space so
you couldn't really move around that
well but you know bring them out into
the open keep all these puff balls away
from us I mean I'm getting kind of into
this though because like this is that
factor that sort of similarity to like
Dark Souls and blood one that kind of
gets me hooked
except with guns which I enjoy the chat
is paying their respects in the chat
yeah that's how you got this looks like
pyramid ad from silo knows I don't for
sure
I mean he was like approach and super
slow too yeah that's the ominous stuff
right
interesting Charbel says you need to
dodge into him not around which would
make sense right if he's like swinging a
sword that you might be a little
vulnerable space right in the hug zone
chaotic revenge to have grenades see I'm
looking at my bottom left are you okay
just like toss those would you block
that you can block a need definitely I
should be worried you know pulling from
some sort of evil energy you can make
some crazy damage builds in this game my
friend made a one shot crit bills I can
do about 15k damage in one shot dang
that's a cool thing about RPGs is uh the
right build could be some pretty cheap
stuff a sauna play how cute they are
oh okay like you're like where is he why
um get to open space go in like the
middle over there okay we're good right
now we got some space now oh okay he
runs a little bit he reserves his right
to run
I did not mean to do that Wow through
the pillar what a guy like chat is
already paying their respects it's not
like a three hitch string oh dang oh
okay that was there isn't it from like
Call of Duty or something like that yeah
so I got a dodge into him right that's
what the chats oclc bleeding oh nice a
Ledge we've found his weakness
oh no never mind he climbs Ritchie says
just Dodgeville forever
what do we have that can break shield
nothing
oh man we're bleedin I can hear my
heartbeat over what Dragonheart give me
stirring - this guy is nuts I'm gonna
try we've got like 20-some minutes I'm
trying yeah yeah this is our goal oh my
gosh well I mean when he does that
charge - he's open to attack so I can
just like right I can just unload on him
you don't have to make a decision right
like him like hit maybe one or two shots
or maybe one shot and then go for the
dodge because once he starts lashing
it's done you know it's a few he does
like a three string little combo of area
so you're probably blast him roll yeah
and then blast him again and then roll
you might not have enough time actually
you might have to like blast some roll
and then roll again because I think
there's a little bit of a delay between
the second and third right Richie those
weren't grenades I tried using them
there it was it ended up being a blast
oh man is this on highest difficulty yes
I'm sure we don't know but the answer is
yes yeah exactly just frame they look
cute and scary at the same time like
when they hop to you they're kind of
cute I do not agree with that
send them in I just think they're creepy
I hear dead people okay well did you did
you came out from like here
well maybe gotta kill all of his
children trade or no real upset well I
kind of check out all his little crab
friends okay so when you dodge roll into
him to get behind him
oh that makes sense oh gosh you guys not
like literally yeah yeah towards them
yeah phrasing man that's the tactic
right
oh there you look he's fun he's like my
babies oh wait that's someone new he oh
you're about to start coughing oh you're
infected maybe the flask is for that
nice well okay the flask looks like it's
a 10-minute bus and it cleared here
oh there you got him we haven't run into
any blocks glitches yeah oh yeah for
asking
RJ asked okay well I'm almost out of
pistol ammo good thing that monster
dropped a couple of rounds for you
where's this other guy though god that
was oh I hear I'm yelling where's your
mother
salomina all right josh is terrifying
the the ranged guy was not that bad
I hear him no you don't you really guys
right why did they sound so big and make
this little bar there's so many of them
traveling group next time you guys buy a
bag of cotton balls gonna think twice
about that they might just form a
coalition or NIU whoo gold box oh crap
you know these you know modern games
make me think of gold items so
differently play too much apex and
you're just like gold
yeah must be something good and they're
just like nope it's just iron iron one
piece of it some scrap
David slack says the cycles of guns I'm
in pretty much
all right we've killed a lot of these
little babies and Big Boss does not come
out getting right which you know hey I'm
not either we're like getting to that I
don't know the nest or something
all right just frame thanks for tuning
in have a good night and we'll see you
next time and have a good day at work
tomorrow
whoa you're dying new item ring of
evasion that sounds like something we
need clip a that they all need different
noises oh I can't oh oh he's walking
that is him
oh that's someone new oh oh he has like
a change
oh don't test the same don't test the
same David ding a slow walking you dude
with the
machine gun was like a Gatling gun oh
man
gonna wait follow you're a blonde
without involved was my last oh nice
m'kay Dragon Fire says I've been playing
since the sixteenth with the pre-order
and this game is just so much fun I'm
nearly done with my hard playthrough and
getting to the final boss soon I love it
nice so I guess every time you play
through it you unlock the next
difficulty and then you could play
through again nice is this game on PC
yes it is we're playing on PC now but
it's also on PlayStation and Xbox the
fact that you've fought a couple of
other big Blake right so we yeah we got
all these two of them which is which is
nice but it's kind of sucky cuz I'm like
really low you only have one more potion
mm-hmm correction zero potions those
little SS blasts I'm probably gonna die
no happy I have zero faith
come on chat press f4 feet do this
reload speed is sure
Oh
even like your computer
we got a I guys fed up with these little
guys holy man I would like something
more than scrap please some bad this
game can be played alone and co-op so
yeah option Thank You Chad Jeff's four
feet in the Bob Jones died he can dodge
a wrench you can dodge a cotton I think
we're near the God be near that one guy
cuz he was near like we passed the marsh
yeah well maybe cuz I mean it it is
random right maybe this time he just
didn't spawn and it was those other two
guys instead mmm interesting which I'm
kind of like that's totally fine if
that's the case I think we finally did
clear all of this out there is one find
a new way that I die okay beyond the
subway tunnels okay so this area that's
still kind of blocked out Oh gotcha
gotcha gotcha so we'll try and like
speed through it but I also do want to
kind of heal up and get my right waitin
do you have to build the heals you pick
them up or you go to the the thing oh
right right you recharge your
Dragonheart taha memory it's a thing so
we got a discover the rest of the subway
tunnel we're gonna heal up real quick
our magical crystal and take a rest
Thanks I think it might it might respond
all those guys but you know whatever
we're not
we're just gonna find a streamline path
oh snap
mystical Nisha's back what's up welcome
hope you're having a nice Tuesday okay
assassin says yeah sometimes the same
same enemies don't respawn where they
worried keep dying the game was like
clearly this boss you are a breeze but
hey but we got two of them
we got the long-range Bogue eye and we
got the big boy with the machine gun and
it looks like you just spawned everyone
back again so you might run into them
one more time that's fun
will there be any season pass or DLC for
for this game I do not know it did just
officially drop today
so I'm not sure yet but honestly in this
day and age I wouldn't doubt it I
wouldn't thought there'd be some sort of
expansion or something down the road but
it's pretty awesome so far I mean just
for what they have be seen so even with
no announcements of DLC I don't think
that should be anything to stop anyone
from trying it out oh snap hello from
the UK says j67 what's up man welcome I
always like seeing where everyone's from
and where they tune in from mm-hmm you
guys Rock
oh my gosh two cotton balls
oh my gosh that sounded new Gatling gun
men all right let's get those uh okay
nice the dragon hot
that's how God like dragons are that
like in so many games something dragon
related either helps you heals you hmm
does something cool I always just sing
at Dragon Tales but you know what's cool
- how much does this cost this is 40
bucks
across the board PC PlayStation and Xbox
but actually you know isn't bad mm-hmm
most brand-new games online on launch
are like 60 bucks crankset classic ledge
trick I see what you're doing that's
that a you know third-person shooter
environmental habits yeah you ever seen
this again cuz I can totally see why the
devs were like strongly urging you to
play this co-op right get some help yeah
get some help you need help and this is
normal
imagine what the Alonzo
Richard Gomez says for the little
minions use your melee weapons so you
don't waste ammo that's a good point
although they're dropping in the ammo
poor you know for me to keep going and
when I try doing the melee
I just got swarmed by them mail is too
slow yeah at least with them the
scrapper which is interesting you would
think the scrapper would have better
melee combat a little faster you know
got some blood wards oh nice
Kinnison said you're that big girl I did
oh yeah it's a machine gun guy who
sounds like him I hear his gun wear it
[Music]
me switch shoulders
I don't know how it's always been my
thing about third person tutors if you
can switch shoulders it's really
convenient now on that's not what I
wanted to do
now we've got this oh he's smart
oh hi cotton balls were to shop oh my
gosh oh my god you're dead what do they
come from a man that's like ah there's
no sound or nothing gosh frustrated
mm-hm creep up on you Reggie's like stop
it get some help Michael Jordan get some
kelp Oh get some kelp uh I always
appreciate some good spongebob
preferences unless that's not a
spongebob reference but I'm pretty sure
yeah but I mean you can switch shoulders
you just have to I don't know maybe go
to your control settings I might tell
you which one I'm thinking you might
need it to maneuver weight controls go
over are be like three more times she
attacks which weapon Crouch dodged
camera scope quick slot sprint shift
camera movement dragon heart aim at body
it's probably like aim and then press
something yeah yeah to switch pops and
Kat said those little cotton balls earn
their paychecks good little employee
team effort here they have families to
feed bills to pay you know they're just
doing their job David Holub Swedish
meatballs that's cute you feel like I
like that one Swedish meatballs
just calm IKEA Oh click the stick so
it's coughing at
aha Thank You chat watch the chat in
their infinite wisdom
no there is no hipfire because just
right trigger by it's only oh he's back
all right we got it we got a oh we got a
resume Irv ass
oh my god he's good oh my gosh
dragon hurt oh we have no dragon heart
no we do how we do we do okay you're
bleeding you're about to get sick I'm
out again
get away God he got his bonus I hate
that guy man it's like if I if he can
just 1v1 me fair fight see me on the
court we're good 1v1 me bro but but no
he needs to use this his needs to go to
Ikea first guy with a couple Swedish
meatballs
hit him up you're like yo man you know
what we're gonna do we're gonna ruin
morning oh yeah I'm down for that
[Laughter]
it's like what's in it for me is well
let me see your bling well the entire
time but the second you saw that boss
you're like well again I mean the
problem is too is like I think one this
might just you know you can probably
just chalk this up to difficulty and
just one issue that I'm having is it's
just the time to like and DA just like
there's not enough space for me to
that was fantastis ish in me
oh you're about to explode do that
that's the Yolo life right there you
know there's only one way to do that Oh
which stick did you press right snicker
let's see that's it I kept trying to do
the right six that's what I'm used to so
80s and then left stick you know do apex
things we don't reload we switch weapons
how many of you are there a lot someone
was getting busy at some point
oh no oh no I'll go there yeah oh this
is so how do you how do you like the
moment that he shows out I'm just gonna
like toss the control oh boy Oh God all
the aggression yes all the moves in the
chat big oof
oh that was a nice double wombo combo so
it's just that it's my ankle up and
everybody else is just like yeah just
they're all collateral show your face
man why do you got out what do you gotta
wait for me to get like it's worn by
like 12 ikea swedish meatballs and then
and then you come out like yeah ain't
got the smart tactics
oh man they got each other's back not
today
ride or die oh now Yuri I was talking
injured I hear somebody all right you
got this like we know guys meatballs me
where you got this optimal get those
reactions nice noise oh this is free oh
let's go let's go easy games over guys
we won we just beat the hardest boss in
the hole oh here first funding spotlight
five minutes to spare geez alright let's
let's ask this philosopher so let's just
go fool I'm so glad we've been recording
this whole session also yeah me too put
this top chair gameplay up on channel
ASAP
you flatter me
what are friends for we run and we run
and we ignore those guys crime said Gigi
let's go home yes very nice job and then
of crisis as in here to bust everyone's
bubble that wasn't a boss what is be
proud of ourselves for five seconds oh
my god not all of us are top tier
remnant professionals from the remnant
gaming League like you are okay the
remnant Championship Series all come on
oh now we got Machine Man machine gun
men
I respect you still going for headshots
despite the fact that Lake is that
really his head though got a glitch yeah
let me know if that's actually we're
going for it
man oh we need some big damage there we
go
give me your luminite crystal you did it
over anytime the AI confirms that it's
over
must be over yeah alright now we can
explore the other part of the BART we
didn't get to yet yeah well I think I
think this might even be the end of this
wall section here
nice well whoo right on time yeah I say
well you guys we did indeed have a great
time playing some remnant today you know
just checking out a little bit of the
beginning some of this first mission but
of course it just came out today you
guys so if you want to see more you want
to check it out and then get it today it
is on Xbox Playstation and PC we were
playing on PC just now obviously you can
use controller as well
all up to you guys on how you want to
play just go and put alright anything
else before we sign off David no yeah
we're gonna have a lot of gameplay clips
guides things like that coming up soon
on our YouTube channels and on site
we're gonna have the review for this
game somewhat soon so you guys should
definitely check it out if you're
interested in it you're a blood-borne
fan Dark Souls fan RPG fan it's worth
it's worth a shot I think it's a lot of
fun you only enjoy just a game fan check
it out or just a game fan exactly if you
haven't played any of those Souls games
and why not try it maybe you might go
back and play some Souls games
afterwards if you're a masochist after
this yeah but thank you guys for tuning
in so much all the returning faces we
see we really appreciate you guys coming
back every day we will be here tomorrow
with some more awesome GameSpot live
action so be sure to tune in and have a
good one we'll see you guys later guys
take it easy